- The framework that most people have
is fast and me.
It's fast and what do I get?
And it is obvious to me
that the unlock for the 90% of this room
is slow and them.
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
It is good to be here.
Hello everyone.
(audience cheering)
Please sit, sit, let's do this.
So the way we structured today's talk
is I'm gonna talk for 30 minutes
and then we are gonna do 30 minutes of Q&A
which I think are in
the corners over there
they'll set that up.
But first of all,
thank you so much for the warm welcome.
I'm super excited to be here.
I touched down earlier today
and there's a lot of different things
I'd like to touch on
but what I'm gonna speak about
is really things that I hope
lead to more detailed questions
when we get into the Q&A session.
And so there's really two things
that I think about
which is one of the reasons I talk a lot
about things like clouds and dirt
or macro, micro,
or not being half
pregnant or in the middle
is I genuinely believe that when I analyze
things that have worked for me,
for the businesses I admire,
for other people that
have created success,
I think that you need
to play in the edges.
What I mean by that is
upper funnel, lower funnel.
What I mean by that is brand and sales.
What I mean by that is scalable activities
and then non-scalable activities.
For me, one of the more
interesting things I did today
was on the drive here
for about 40 minutes,
I was just replying to a
bunch of different texts
that I've got from a text
platform that I've created,
one by one.
Every smart business friend I have
would consider it a waste of time,
not a good use of my time
and for me, those 39 to 44 people
that actually got a detailed answer
it created depth in the
relationship that I have with them.
I genuinely believe that people struggle
with scaling non-scalable behavior.
I believe that anybody here
who has more than 10 employees
does not spend enough time
in one on one meetings
with those employees
or having sense of what they want,
not what we want out of those employees.
And so I've been spending a lot of time
thinking about activities
that actually lead
to what somebody wants.
When I think about
somebody buying a ticket
to an event like this
and spending all day,
it means that they're
looking for information,
they're looking for a hack or an insight
or a framework that helps them succeed.
And for me, the reality is
as my profile continues to grow,
somebody asked me earlier today
a question that led me to answering
most people don't act on
what I'm talking about.
So much of what I'm talking about
is very based in patience.
It's very based in
grinding, work ethic work.
I'm so not interested
in anything short term.
And I feel like everyone is attracted
to the next big platform
or block chain and cryptocurrency
or cannabis
or a quick trade or investment.
Let it be very clear, Sydney,
that the way I think about the world
sits in decades, not in months.
Almost half the questions I've got
on text and DM in the last month
were framed in a version of,
hey Gary Vee, how can I
make a lot of money quickly?
And there may not be a
single person on Earth
that is worse at answering
that question than me.
My ability or interest
in creating quick money
is almost nonexistent
and I'm fascinated by how few people win
in quick moves
yet the majority of
people are looking for it.
There is no system.
There is no passive income framework.
There is no sure bet.
There is no guaranteed return.
There is lunch pail and hard
hat day in and day out grinding
and trying to bring value
to the people that you're
trying to sell something to.
And it's in perpetuity.
And so we are so fortunate
to be living during this time
where the internet on your phone
has created such substantial
scale for all of us.
None of our grandparents
had the luxury of being able
to build something significant
that they could live off of
on the power of something
that was in their pocket.
And yet, everybody is
looking for the why nots
instead of the why's
meaning I am fascinated by the
ability right now of humans
to demonize technology.
Kids should be off iPads more,
social media leads to
anxiety and negativity.
We are demonizing these technologies
because what these technologies
are doing right now
is they're exposing us,
they're not changing us.
Instagram and Facebook and Twitter
don't force you to be a dick
face on their platforms.
We're doing that.
And so we live in this time
where there's so much opportunity.
And let me tell you how
this opportunity works out.
In its most simple,
every single person in this room,
whether they're trying
to build a personal brand
and speak and write books
or they're trying to sell
their new bikini brand
direct-to-consumer,
or their cereal,
or real estate or financial advice,
or running for mayor or president,
whatever you're doing in this room
from that corner to that corner,
unless you have the attention of people
and unless you articulate
what you want to happen
in a form that makes
them want to act on it,
you are completely irrelevant.
The reason I pump out so much content
in written, audio and
video form every single day
across 10 different platforms,
including podcast, email and
my text messaging platform
is because the cost of entry
to be successful in society
is predicated on communicating at scale.
If you do not understand that part,
if you do not understand
that there's an enormous need
to make compelling content,
to excite somebody to consider to do
whatever you're up to,
unless you understand that framework,
you are outrageously vulnerable.
Just 'cause you think your
videos are funny or good,
doesn't mean they do.
Just because you think you
make the best chocolate shake,
if nobody knows about it,
it's not gonna matter.
So please understand what the
internet is actually doing.
What the internet is
actually doing at scale
is its shrinking the value of everything
besides communication.
If you're not building brand or awareness,
you're becoming irrelevant.
What's fascinating to me about that
is so many people have those ambitions
but they're not creating
the actions that lead to it.
I was on the radio this
morning when I first got here
and somebody called and said,
I'm trying to build my
whole business on Instagram
and photography.
And I asked him how many
times a day are you posting?
He said once.
And I said to myself,
you're trying to build your entire life
based on Instagram
and you genuinely believe
posting one time a day
is going to be the gateway to that?
I was looking at a lot of people
that were leaving comments
or tagging this event all day
and I went on their Instagram accounts,
about 40 people I would
say during the day.
Of those 40 people,
only two people actually replied
to people's comments on Instagram.
The amount of people here that
want to grow on that platform
yet the small community that
they have that actually reply
to their content,
they don't have time to
reply and say thank you
or continue the conversation,
fascinates the shit out of me.
We are in the most
selfish framework society
that I have ever seen.
Every single person is so focused
on what they want from other people
yet they deploy no value in
return to the other person
for what they want.
The gateway to everything
you're trying to get
out of this conference
is empathy and being selfless
yet that is the least
attractive thing to most people.
People are so worried
about how they're gonna
get to a expensive watch
or private plane or fancy vacation,
that they're confused of
how you actually get there.
And so I am unbelievably passionate
in starting to continue the
process that I've been on
over the last 15 years
which is to put pressure
on this room to understand
unless you're bringing value,
you will become irrelevant
because what the internet also does
is it allows every one of us to play.
The reason so many people ask me
what the next big platform is
is 'cause they're far more interested
in playing a game of being first
versus playing a game of being best.
Right now, there are seven platforms,
YouTube, Facebook, Twitter,
LinkedIn, Instagram,
and on and on
that are at enormous scale,
that if you were good at it,
you would get enormous value.
You would get unlimited customers,
you would get unlimited opportunities,
yet day in and day out
people continue to not want
to be what they need to be
which is let me remind
everybody very simply
if you are not remarkable
at creating content that is post produced
to understand the context
of the platform that you're posting on
and more importantly,
the psychology of people
when they're on it,
you will lose.
Meaning you can't post the same picture
on Twitter and Instagram and LinkedIn
and think you're gonna
get the same result.
People are in a different mindset.
Also, those platforms work differently.
They have different
ways to format pictures,
different lengths of creative.
This is one masterful
game of communication.
The reason we know the people
that we know in history,
whether Muhammad Ali or Gandhi
is because they were great
communications hackers
above and beyond what they were
actually doing for a living.
Everybody here now
has the luxury of having the internet
be the platform that
they can communicate on.
Yet, we have bum rushed
into a game of hacking
or looking for shortcuts
or the thing that will break through
versus becoming craftsmen and craftswomen
on these platforms.
It has become very clear to me,
especially recently,
that a game of best at communication
is the reason that I get
the honor of standing here tonight,
that I put in ungodly amounts of hours
understanding these platforms
and people's behaviors on them,
that I lack the fear of having a post,
where I was about to
go with that sentence,
I just cut myself off
because one of the things
that I'm most excited about
in the last decade in social media
is actually being tested
here in Australia,
which is Instagram
eliminating likes on posts.
To me, this is one of the
great moves in a long time
in the industry
because so many people
have become so deeply insecure
that all they really do with their content
is post things that they
know will get the most likes.
The amount of muscle dudes
who want to talk about other things
that DM me and say,
I want to talk about these other things
but when I post photos without my shirt
I get the most likes
so I keep doing it.
And the conversations of when I ask them
why do you do that
and they don't even know,
they're caught in the
machine of getting more likes
than talking about the thing
they actually give a shit about.
We are living in unprecedented times.
Every person in this
conference, including myself,
is grossly underestimating the internet.
This is the singular
invention of the human race.
It is the most important thing
that has happened to humans
since the printing press.
It has completely changed the
global political landscape.
It has completely changed
the leverage of human beings ability.
There is literally nothing
stopping every person in this room
from getting whatever they want
because there is no man in the middle.
The platforms have all the leverage
and the consumer in the end
is the actual punchline.
So here are the things that
I'm most passionate about,
A, if you are capable
of starting a podcast
around the thing you do,
I highly recommend you use this talk
to inspire you to do so
and let me explain why.
I believe that podcasts
have almost like a triple hack to them.
Number one,
podcasts are being consumed
at a remarkable rate.
How many people in this audience,
please raise your hands,
listen to podcasts on a weekly basis?
Raise your hands.
Actually, stand up.
I want everybody to see this.
Please stand up if you listen to podcasts
and I want everybody to look around.
We're talking about 90% of this audience,
80% of this audience.
Thank you, please sit.
If you can start a podcast,
even if you have 1,000 people listening,
you don't have to be a top
100 podcast in the world.
You need to have the people
that you're trying to actually reach.
If you have a podcast,
what also happens out of a podcast
is incredibly important.
If you're thoughtful enough
when you do your podcast
to also film it,
what ends up happening
is now you have video content
for YouTube and Facebook and LinkedIn.
If you also are disciplined enough
to then transcribe the interview
you have with somebody,
you now have written
content for those platforms.
If you're extremely thoughtful,
you invite guests
who you actually want to do business with.
When you're cold calling to do business,
they ignore you.
When you invite somebody
to be a guest on your podcast,
they're flattered.
I highly recommend
if you've been debating it
to use this evening
as the push to start that podcast.
Number two, regardless of what you do,
you started a shampoo
brand for 15 year olds,
you have to start looking at LinkedIn.
LinkedIn over the last year and a half,
and I believe for at
least another year or two,
based on the way I'm looking at it
is acting more like Facebook 2011
than any platform I've seen prior.
It's been very fascinating to watch
LinkedIn be a place
where you don't have to
just do business content.
Yes, the psychology of people on there
is a little more business-oriented
but if you were in the B2B business,
how many people here consider themselves
in the B2B business?
Raise your hand.
One more time,
a little higher, if you don't mind.
I mean if you are not posting
four, five, six times a day,
and when I say posting,
this goes back to the way I
framed up this conversation.
You have to make content
that brings value to them
isn't a sales pitch for you.
Most of the content that
I see on every platform
is so self serving, nobody gives a shit.
Nobody wants to be sold to.
There's too many other options.
This isn't late night
television or infomercials
where there was only 36 channels.
This is the internet.
It's unlimited content
and there's a lot of good shit out there.
So if you're not putting out
good shit, you're finished.
You're not gonna will your way to victory.
LinkedIn for everybody who
just raised their hand on B2B
is going to go away in its organic reach,
just like Facebook and Instagram do.
You have to strike now.
Please have a very
significant LinkedIn strategy.
Please start finding a way
to produce more content.
If you don't know how,
if you don't know what to say,
create a Q&A framework.
Email blast your consumers
and ask them what questions they have
and then turn that into content.
Figure it out.
Have guests.
You have to challenge,
so to me, podcast and LinkedIn
are remarkably out of control.
How many people sell a
product on the internet
through Shopify or things of
that nature, sell something?
Raise your hands.
For this group,
I want to talk about influencer marketing.
I believe that influencer marketing
is at a maturity level
that a lot of people
think that it's now over
or it's too expensive or they missed it.
My belief
is that we're five seconds
into influencer marketing,
that influencer marketing
is here in perpetuity
because word of mouth is,
that influencer marketing
is unbelievably underpriced
if you're sophisticated on your end
and understand how to not overpay
and that if you sell any product
that you must absolutely get serious
about influencer marketing
because over every other
option in communication
when done right at scale
it returns the biggest ROI.
The problem is most people
are chasing the whales
of people that have millions of followers
and many of those people
are now overpriced
because the follow count
is the metric that they're selling against
meanwhile with my sneakers
and my wine products
many people that have 3,000
or 5,000 or 8,000 people
tend to be driving my biggest results
because they have deep engaged audience
and enormous trust in that audience.
And so if you're on the consumer side,
I highly recommend that
you go down that path.
The luxury of being 43 years old
and operating businesses
every day of my life
for over 20 years is the following,
I operated prior to the
internet being at scale
and mobile phones being at scale.
What that means is
when I did direct mail and newspapers
and television and billboards
to build my dad's liquor store
everything cost a lot of money.
It was very expensive
and if you were at zero,
you had no fucking shot.
We sit here tonight
with the internet at scale,
that if you're here and you
have not started any of this
and you've got nothing going on,
that tomorrow, at the cost of zero,
only your sweat equity,
you can start the process of
building something meaningful.
The excuses that fly at scale
to why we haven't or why you haven't
or why it hasn't happened
is very difficult for
somebody like me to swallow
in a world where I didn't
have these options.
If I had fucking Ebay and
Instagram when I was 15,
I would've been a trillionaire by 19.
We are sitting in the easiest time
to be a successful entrepreneur.
In not so many words,
if you're not successful
right now, you suck.
And what I mean by that is
we have a frothy global economy,
things are good at scale,
we have internet at scale,
cost zero.
If you are not successful right now,
you're in a bad spot
because the playing field is easier
than it's ever been in the
history of the human race.
That's not a dig.
I'm not interested in razzing.
I'm not trying to be
Debbie fucking downer.
I'm trying to create a
very logical conversation
that if you're not,
you need to recognize that 80% likely
you're trying to make it happen too fast
because deep down you're so insecure
that you need financial success
to cover up your pain
or B, you just might not be good at it
and what you should do
is what a lot of my friends did
which they became employee
number 13 and 19 and 25
at Facebook and Uber
and I promise you, employee
number 54 at Facebook
made more money than
every person in this room,
including me right now.
Self awareness is the most
important conversation
in our society.
The rise of entrepreneurship
and the coolness
has forced so many people
into thinking they need to be one.
Entrepreneurship is a skill
no different than playing
a professional sport
or being a professional performer.
I implore you to use tonight
as an opportunity
to start finally being
honest with yourself
and asking yourself a series of questions
around what you're good at
and what you like.
When somebody is lucky enough
to be great at what they like,
they achieve ridiculous levels of success.
Most people are not fortunate enough
to have those serendipities
because they limit
themselves from trying things
or they deploy delusion
around their ideology
of what they wish they were
instead of looking at themselves
and figuring out what they actually are.
I cannot be more clear
in my statement of how
easy it is to be successful
on the internet today.
It's just the truth.
I mean when I just think
about the ability to sell
stuff on the internet
and the infrastructure cost being so low,
I just am passionate
to make sure everybody understands
what's happening in the macro,
which is very simply
nothing makes me laugh more
than when people get mad at the algorithms
for a platform that is fucking free.
People are like, Zuck's
is trying to fuck me.
Zuck's charged zero
dollars for your account.
We are doing an awful job in the macro
of understanding the
opportunity in front of us
and more importantly,
when we have something that works
squeezing the shit out of it
and getting the most value out of it.
So many people get upset with platforms
because they did get there
early enough and it was easy
and when it tightens up
because ad spend comes in
and starts filling the feed,
they get sad that they don't get
the free impressions anymore.
We have to heed the moments.
When I come up here
and I articulate in this mood,
not the mood that some
of you normally see me in
around the opportunity in LinkedIn,
the opportunity in podcasts,
the opportunity in influencer marketing,
many of you, and I've watched
you, shake your heads.
You understand those truths.
You dap each other if you've
been doing it a little bit.
But the reality is are
you going 120 on it?
Do you understand that the target moves?
Do you understand that if I
come back here in 18 months,
I mean look, my last
book I wrote Crushing It
which only came out 18 months ago
I didn't even mention
LinkedIn in the book.
It wasn't even in the book.
Because that's how fast all
of the attention changes.
Musical.ly's crushing it three
years ago with 13 year olds,
then it dies 'cause of the acquisition
then it reforms itself
and comes back as TikTok
and now it really matters.
The speed in which this
all is evolving is enormous
which means the capabilities
you need to have
are enormous.
But this starts with self awareness
and auditing your skillset.
If you look at my career
from 1996 to today,
I have been on top of and a contemporary
and a great executer of
almost every shift except one.
I am silent from 2002 to 2006
because that was the
era when blogs exploded.
And I can't write for shit.
There is nobody
who has five New York
Times bestselling books
that writes worse than me on Earth.
The reason I couldn't
take advantage of blogs
was I couldn't write,
I was self aware enough that I couldn't,
I didn't have the money or infrastructure
to hire a writer to do it
and so I had to take that L
and miss that era
with enormous frustration.
We do not have that issue anymore
because with internet at scale
written word, audio and video
and the ability to go live with
your audience are all here.
You have the ability
to reverse engineer your
passions and strengths
and deploy them.
The problem is the framework
that most people have
is fast and me.
It's fast and what do I get?
And it is obvious to me
as I stand here tonight
that the unlock for the 90% of this room
is slow and them.
Slow and them.
And that's how I see the world.
How has what happened to me happened?
Because every time I post every single day
I'm trying to think about why
would that bring you value?
Why do a lot of people come
to this event to see me?
It's because I've brought them value.
It's because something I've said or done
gave them value.
I am fascinated by how every single day
I try to articulate in different forms,
whether in cartoon form, in cursing form,
in audio form, in picture form,
how do I get people to understand
how enormous the opportunity is
and how amazing it is for us
to be alive during this era?
Please use this tone,
and by the way, we're about to go to Q&A,
so couple things,
I know the mic is over there,
so anybody who wants to,
yep, they're waving their hands,
so anybody who wants to rush,
this is it,
this is your chance to ask the question,
and line up over here.
So do not be bashful.
Do not regret it.
I really want to go into the Q&A.
I've said what I had to say which is
please don't let this era go by.
Please,
let me put the real pressure on,
I am scared that many of
you will send me an email
in 15 years and say,
hey, you probably don't remember this,
but you were in Sydney in 2019,
you said all these things
and I didn't act on them and I wish I did.
And I get those emails all the time
'cause I bring this up
in a lot of my talks
over the last 15 years,
just don't.
Please challenge yourself,
if it's not clicking right now,
it's not gonna get easier.
This is the easiest it's ever been.
The economy globally will
go the other direction.
There was a nice little blip in China
just 48 hours ago.
You get a couple more of those blips
and it gets real hard real fast.
I just am desperate for
people to start understanding
they need to attack.
Sydney, please attack.
Please take my focused energy this evening
in understanding that there's no reason
to be passive anymore
in your communication.
Nothing matters more
than communicating on an every
day basis on the internet,
nothing, nothing.
There's no system,
there's no funnel,
nothing matters more than
bringing value to the end consumer
in content on a daily basis
as an awareness play
to what you do for a living, nothing.
It's called building brand.
It takes a long time
but it will absolutely be the best thing
that you possibly do.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Let's go.
- [Male] Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- [Male] Good thanks.
Yourself?
- I'm amazing.
- [Male] Great, great.
So I own a company called Logo Social.
The question I've got for you
is should I be focusing on
Sydney for paid advertising
or should I be trying to hit
like every major city around the world?
- Well how are you doing in Sydney?
- [Male] To be honest,
a lot of our purchases
are in Sydney and Paris.
So I'm trying to think
if I should be aiming
more at Europe as well or,
'cause of the time zones
and the different seasons?
- Well look, I mean I think
wide and deep both work,
it just comes down to your skillset.
If you thnk yorue converting
more business in Europe
for some rhyme or reason
then that's where you want to focus.
I'm unemotional about
where business comes from.
I just want to make sure
that it's not an ideology that
you want to be fucking global
and that's why you do it.
I'm hoping you're doing it
because it's in the best
interest of your business.
- [Male] Yeah definitely.
Yeah, it's just because of like
the summer here and the winter there,
just trying to make
sales and create content
for each sort of country
and making it work for us.
- I'm not sure what mother
nature has to do with this
but what do you mean by that?
- [Male] Just with the different seasons.
This time of year, it's winter here
so we're creating more--
- Winter content.
- [Male] Yeah, yeah, basically.
Summer over there
and trying to create content,
create clothing for both times of year
and spreading across that.
- Yeah, I don't see that as a challenge.
The reality is that's the cost of entry
and where the context of the market is,
that's what you have to do.
So, all right, thanks mate.
Hey.
- [Ninos] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- [Ninos] Good, how are you?
- Tremendous.
- [Ninos] Awesome.
My name is Ninos.
I run a small real estate
photography company.
Basically,
I've consistently managed
to beat my current salary
'cause I work full time as well.
My question is when
is the right time--
- You mean your side hustle
makes more money than your actual job?
- [Ninos] For the past six months, yes.
- Okay.
- [Ninos] My question
is when's the right time
to quit the job
- Now.
- And go full time?
Right now?
- Right now.
(audience cheering)
And before everybody claps for you,
you may fail
but the reality is you can
always get another fucking job.
- [Ninos] Yeah.
Can always get another shitty job.
- The time is now.
If you're outperforming your regular job
with your side hustle,
you will be dumbfounded
by what actually happens
when you go full time.
- [Ninos] I only work about
two hours a day at it.
- You mean at your work?
- [Ninos] No, at my side hustle.
- That's what I mean.
When you convert that to 13 hours,
you're gonna easily
trump what you're doing
in your regular job salary
above and beyond and closing that gap.
- [Ninos] Sure.
Fucking love you man.
- Love you back.
- Let's go, Gary.
- [Lucy] Hi Gary, my name is Lucy Lin.
I'm the founder of (mumbles).
- How are you?
- [Lucy] I'm good, thank you.
Thank you so much for coming to Sydney.
We're all very excited.
- I'm excited to be here.
I fucking love this city.
(people cheering)
- [Lucy] I have an
innovation marketing company
and what we do is a lot of marketing
to emerging technology companies
and with this, it's all about
taking new products and
services out to market,
especially if they're
using new technologies
like block chain and
smart cities, et cetera.
How do you educate people
who's in a brand new space?
What's your best educational methods
of taking things out to market?
- I put out the content for free.
What's unique about what I do
is I give away all of
VaynerMedia's secrets
on a daily basis for free.
- [Lucy] Yeah.
- And most people think that's stupid.
Most people think the
information they have
is what they're selling.
I think the contextual
execution is what I sell
and the way that we grow in new areas
is because I'm putting
out the content for free.
So I think you should make white papers
and videos and podcasts
about the information for free.
- [Lucy] Okay.
And that's the best way of
educating brand new spaces?
- Of course
'cause then you're
creating content at scale
and it just naturally
educating the market.
- [Lucy] Okay, fantastic.
Thank you so much.
- The other thing to consider
with a business like yours
is to do more work for free.
People are unbelievably resistant
to doing free work
but to me, free work is usually
the gateway to paid work
and the amount of people
that have audacity
to not do free work
when nobody's fucking
paying them blows my mind.
- [Lucy] How much free work can I do?
- As much as you can bear.
- [Lucy] Without eating
instant noodles every night?
- Noodles are delicious
when you're trying to get to caviar.
- [Lucy] Very true, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Male] GV, how are you my man?
- I am really good.
- [Male] Very, very good.
Look, there's a big concern
spending two to three years
with a lot of hard work
building up a brand across these platforms
only to have a platform go obsolete.
Is there a way to ensure,
as platforms come and go,
all the hard work that we do?
- No.
Because people are confused.
When you brand properly for
those two or three years,
you get the brand value.
When I crushed Twitter from 2007 to '11,
I got the brand value
even though Twitter declined after that.
I still know who Dane
Cook and Tila Tequila are
'cause they crushed MySpace 30 years ago.
Just 'cause you don't reach
as many people organically,
doesn't mean what you did
for two or three years
didn't work.
You didn't keep your users on television
and print and radio and billboards.
We're not here to amass lists
that we can reach in perpetuity.
We're here to build brand.
- [Male] Is there a strong way
to transfer those users on the platform
to new platforms as they come,
if you can see them declining?
- Yes, bring fucking value to them
while you've got them on the
platform and their attention
and they will fucking
find you on the new shit.
- [Male] Thanks Gary.
- You're welcome.
Like you want to hear something funny?
I wish everything that was
relevant right now disappeared
and we all started over
tomorrow on paper.com.
I'd be the most followed
fucker in the world.
Hello.
- [Male] Hey Gary, how are you mate?
I've got an innovation
that has a global patent on it.
It's an Australian innovation.
And I want to get it at scale globally.
There's 200 big end products
per atom in this space
and this innovation does
like 15 innovations in one
and I'm wondering,
there's a lot of Australian
company owners here
and you're obviously a guy
that's very successful.
Do you invest in Australian businesses
and Australian companies
and do you ever look at a product
that might come from out of Australia?
I started marketing
when I was 19.
- Yes.
I was an early investor in Canva
and other Australian, sure.
I don't give a shit where it comes from.
If it's good, I'm interested.
- [Male] We had a thing
called Overseas and Undersold.
I studied when I was 19.
Now 46
and literally Australia's
got a really good innovation hub here.
- I agree.
- [Male] I'd love to talk to you
or get in contact with
your staff at some stage.
Thank you, mate.
Legend.
- You're welcome.
- [Meg] Hi Gary.
Welcome to Sydney.
- Thank you.
- [Meg] My name's Meg.
I have a active wear brand
called Valkyrie Athletic.
My question is how to
stay fresh and relevant
in an oversaturated industry?
- By innovating product
or your communication.
It's not super complicated.
It's the same game that
Nike or Under Armour
or Adidas have battled
for every fashion brand.
When you have a brand like that
there's only two ways you win,
you innovate product
or you innovate the way you communicate
to the end consumer.
- [Meg] Right, I'm trying to do both.
I've been following all your advice,
got a podcast going.
It seems to be working pretty well.
I have a second question.
I'm about to move to London
and I want to come and
work for VaynerMedia.
How do I do that?
- You apply.
- [Meg] Obviously.
Any tips to stand out?
- You know, it's funny,
we don't have, we're really kind of funny
in the way we hire.
We go in all sorts of
different directions.
I would say this,
I think Vayner is very
much a people organization.
I would probably go follow
all the people that work at London,
there's about 100 of them
and see if you have common interests
with any of them
and engage in those conversations
on Twitter and other platforms with them
and use that as a gateway
to awareness of you
and then use that to apply.
- [Meg] Thanks Gary.
- You're welcome.
- [Liam] Hey Gary.
- Hey bro.
- Liam, I'm 19 from Perth.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Liam] Yeah, you too.
I'll give you a quick summary.
Basically, 2018 I was diagnosed
with Hodgkins-Lymphoma.
If you don't
know what that is--
- I'm sorry.
I do.
- [Liam] Yep.
Well, so it is about
six months chemotherapy,
few weeks of radiation therapy
and it was like one of the hardest things
I've had to do in my life.
- Of course.
- [Liam] Post coming out of that,
I basically realized fuck this,
I don't want to work a normal job
and it just made me realize
every day is not guaranteed pretty much.
- Yes, that's right.
- [Liam] So I decided to start
my own gym wear apparel company.
- Good for you.
- [Liam] My goal is to basically create
a symbol of strength
and a label that people in my position
can wear and gain strength
and basically realize
that they can make it
through whatever they're going through.
- Okay.
- [Liam] My question is
I do want to eventually at some point
be able to donate free clothes
to these people.
My concerns are that one,
should I wait for my brand
to actually be big
enough to mean something
or should I just like cut the shit
and start doing it now
when it's not really built,
doesn't really mean much?
- If the punch line of the product
is to inspire them and give them courage
and you haven't established that brand,
then you're just giving them clothes.
So usually I'm a,
as you can tell and you probably know,
I tend to be like now,
but I think the way you framed it up,
I wouldn't mind for you to
actually build the storyline
because it's that logo
that's gonna actually deliver
what you're trying to deliver.
- [Liam] Yeah, totally, awesome.
And my second question is
I just brought a hoodie from
me as well to give to you,
if you wouldn't mind,
I'd love to give it to you after.
- You can give it to me now.
- [Liam] Sweet, I'll grab it for you.
Thanks.
- You got it, bro.
- [Nathan] How you going, Gary?
My name's Nathan.
- Nathan, how are you?
- [Nathan] Yeah good, thanks.
You seem pretty chill
and on top of things.
So my question is
how do you handle stress and adversity
in your businesses?
- By realizing it doesn't mean dick.
I mean it.
I have never been able to
really get down on business
because I basically
make pretend in my mind
when something awful happens in business
that instead of this
awful thing that happened,
we had a great day
but I got a phone call
that one of the 10 people
I love the most died
in a horrific accident
and it just wakes me up
and puts me in perspec,
I have business in a very big perspective.
I am unbelievably not interested in money.
I do not validate myself,
I'm not interested in flashy shit.
I'm into the game.
Money is great, it's fine,
it rewards a lot of opportunity
but the stress is easy
when you don't have
your emotions wrapped up
in the success of your business.
- [Nathan] Yeah.
- Like I love doing business.
The reason I garage sale
or go do a week at a baseball
card show, like I just did,
is 'cause I love the process,
not the gifts that are
given to me personally
from the business.
So the stress that I get from business
is extremely low
because I'm not scared to go to zero.
- [Nathan] Yeah, makes sense.
- You understand?
- [Nathan] Yeah.
- And that, if you go deeper,
is grounded in the fact
that I don't give a fuck
what anybody thinks about me.
- [Nathan] Yeah.
- If I completely collapse
and go to zero and everybody here
and all of social and
all of internet says,
see, he was full of shit,
he wasn't good,
I genuinely wouldn't care.
I just have no interest in living my life
based on other people's opinions.
- [Nathan] Thank you.
- I just think you need to
put business in perspective.
And also, I'm thankful for playing.
The cost of entry of being an entrepreneur
is having ridiculously difficult days.
You want to live your
life on your own terms,
of course it should be hard,
otherwise we'd all be doing it.
Perspective.
- [Nathan] Thanks.
- You got it.
- [Samara] Hi Gary.
- Hey.
- [Samara] My name's Samara.
I work for digital media company
called Fish Eye Creative in New Castle.
My question is,
so I have no interest
in being the business
owner or the entrepreneur.
I want to be the best number two.
- I love that.
- [Samara] And I would like to know
what you would say to your number two,
what's the best way to
add to the productivity
and the value of the company
and to assist the number one?
- By reverse engineering the
number one's shortcomings.
- [Samara] Sorry?
- By reverse engineering
the number one's shortcomings.
- [Samara] Okay.
- The best thing a number two can do
is close the gaps of a number one.
- [Samara] Cool.
- Are you a good match to your number one?
- [Samara] Yes.
- Well then that's a good starting point.
- [Samara] Awesome.
Thank you.
- To me, it's about complementary
skills at that level
and so it's just,
a lot of times, number two's struggle
because they want to do
or they're equally have the same talents
as the number one
and that's where friction comes from.
I think it's a game of
complementary skills.
And so the relationships that I've seen
and the ones that have worked for me
is when the number two
is filling in the blanks of the number one
and allowing the number one
to do her or his magic.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I really appreciate
you validating that it's okay
not to be the entrepreneur as well.
I appreciate that.
- Yeah.
My great fear is that as
entrepreneurship has gotten popular
obviously that's been
directly a benefit to me
but I have no interest
in anybody aspiring to
be one when they're not
in the same way that I take a lot of issue
with people thinking
that going to university
is the way to go.
We have to change the conversation
and make this about
happiness and self awareness,
not fucking money.
- [Samara] Yeah, thank you.
- [Ami] Hi Gary.
It's Ami Mishel from Sydney.
- How are you?
- [Ami] Fantastic, thank you.
How are you?
- Really, really good.
- [Ami] I've got a hashtag
question for you, Gary.
We develop residential property
in a regional town called
Oberon, New South Wales.
- Okay.
- [Ami] And if the hashtag
oberonnewsouthwales
isn't popular yet,
what do you do to grow a hashtag
that people wouldn't search for it
unless they knew about it?
- Why would you want it to be popular?
- [Ami] Well I'd want people
to see a small regional town
of 3,600 people
getting $200 million into it
as popular despite it's size.
- But why would you do that in the form
of making a hashtag popular?
- [Ami] Well, I'm more into
people finding the town
and organically looking
at why they should invest money
in my project in that town.
- Well you should do that
by putting out content
to build awareness.
Because a hashtag is not
gonna do that for you.
- [Ami] So content specific for the town
or content of developments
or why you should invest in general?
- Yes.
- [Ami] General?
- Both.
A hashtag is a tactic
that isn't ownable.
I can put out a post right now
of why people should invest in soccer
and proper football cards
and put that hashtag in my post.
Hashtags are not ownable.
And they're not the discovery tool
that you assume they are.
You should run creative
in the form of videos and
probably white papers and decks
and then you should target them
against development investors.
- [Ami] So target the white papers
with the content and then--
- And target the people,
if you're looking for investors,
you may want to go into Instagram
and go against funds that
invest in developments,
not put all your energy
in trying to get a hashtag popular
on Instagram and Twitter
that will lead to nothing.
- [Ami] Wonderful, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Strategy, mother fuckers.
Yes sir.
- [Demi] Hi Gary, I'm Demi.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Demi] I'm just recently
started my own podcast.
- Good.
- [Demi] My question's geared towards
something that I've heard you say
about quantity unlocking quality.
Was there like a moment in time
from when you started doing
your videos with Wine Library,
was there a moment in
time where it just clicked
or did you navigate
through becoming better
speaking on camera or
speaking to an audience?
- I think I had that natural ability.
If you look at the first 60 episodes
of Wine Library TV in 2006,
I was more reserved,
even maybe the demeanor
I'm having tonight.
That was predicated on me worrying
that a lot of the people
that were spending
$100,000 with me in wine
as a 28 year old
would be scared off by my ridiculousness.
But the gift of gab
and having charisma
and being a storyteller
and having a comfort with people
was just naturally in me.
But there's a lot of people
who are not as over the top as me
that are massively successful
because they're their authentic self.
And you don't need to be a showman
to have a top podcast.
Tim Ferriss has an incredible podcast.
He's not over-the-top.
So what you need to do
is lean into your DNA,
not try to have a moment
where you click and become a
different version of yourself.
- [Demi] I was also just thinking
in terms of my self development or yours
would you review your videos
and what you were doing?
- No.
I've never watched a piece of my content.
- [Demi] That's what I do.
- Yeah, I have no interest,
I fucking did it.
- [Demi] Okay, good.
- I know what's in it.
- [Demi] Good, that's how I feel.
Thanks man.
- All right, brother.
Hey.
- [David] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- [David] Hey, good thanks, how are you?
- Super.
- [David] Awesome.
My name is David.
I'm a banker.
I know what you mentioned
that you don't really give a shit
what people think of you
but what do you tell
people that you care about
when they tell you to maybe chill out
or calm down or take it easy.
How do you deal with that?
'Cause you actually care about them.
- I tell them that I love that
and I appreciate where they're coming from
but I have no interest
in telling them how to live their lives
so I'd appreciate if they told me
not how to live mine.
- [David] Awesome, awesome.
Thank you.
- You got it.
- [Chris] Hey Gary.
My name's Chris.
Welcome to Sydney.
- Thank you my friend.
- And I want to say thank you
for your work.
- Thank you, bro.
- [Chris] I thought I would
bring some value to the room.
For smaller business owners,
how do they make content at scale
with limited budget?
Because I work in the creative space
but we hire T1 type companies and stuff.
But I just want you to elaborate
for smaller business owners
how do they keep up to such a demanding
social media space,
Facebook, Instagram and the like?
- By auditing all the dumb shit
that they and their employees do all day
and turn that into making content.
- [Chris] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
I mean listen,
I get those emails all the time,
and I'm like, some store
emailed me the other day
and I went back and forth with her
and I said, do you have cashiers?
She said yeah.
I go, how many are on
during a normal shift?
She said, two.
I said, are they busy?
She said, of course not.
I'm like, so let them make content.
The amount of time
that you actually are wasting
in a day on dumb shit,
including myself, all of us,
is extraordinary.
Anybody who tells me,
Gary, I just watched
your keynote on YouTube.
How do I find time to
make all that content?
I reply with, don't watch an
hour of my fucking keynote.
Hey.
- [Mary Jane] Hey Gary.
Thank you so much for adding so much value
to us in Sydney today
and for coming down under.
- Thank you for saying that.
- [Mary Jane] I'm Mary Jane.
My company's Paper Phoenix
and I own a marketing and
public relations agency.
- Makes sense.
- [Mary Jane] My question
is around authenticity.
Now being someone who controls
another dozen people's
social media accounts.
- Humans?
- [Mary Jane] Yes,
absolutely, all humans.
- That's already
a bad starting point to authenticity.
- [Mary Jane] There you go.
So that's my question is
all these apps have come out now
with automatically replying
for your social media accounts
or even liking
and you don't even know
what they're liking.
Do you think it's a great idea
to invest or keep the
authenticity really real
no matter how long it takes me
to be authentic for my clients?
- You're not authentic
if you're speaking on behalf
of somebody who's not you.
- [Mary Jane] Yeah.
- You're just the human version
of those fucking piece of shit products.
- [Mary Jane] Wish I had
asked another question.
(laughing)
Thank you.
- I mean think about it right,
you're putting judgment on a machine
that is liking or doing all these hacks
that a lot of people love to do
and they don't realize
that at the end of the day
that's gonna fuck them
because it just kills the soul.
- [Mary Jane] Agreed.
- But meanwhile, you're writing
on behalf of another human being.
- [Mary Jane] Correct.
But that's when you try
to get into their business
and understand their business
and not happening either.
All right, just change my job.
- You could do whatever you want.
I think it's way worse for
them than it is for you.
I laugh when people don't think it's me
when I reply to them.
The main reason I get
to stand on this stage
is 'cause it was always me.
Authenticity is only achievable
when it's actually authentic.
- [Mary Jane] Wonderful,
thank you so much.
- You got it.
(audience applause)
- [Female] Hey Gary.
- Hi.
- [Female] So I have a
question about investing
'cause I was just thinking
about starting to invest
but I would like it to be something
that I'm actually interested in.
- Smart.
- [Female] Have you looked
into vegan companies?
- Vegan?
- [Female] Yes.
Because I know a lot of
people say it's a trend
but I think in 10, 20 years
it's not just a trend anymore.
- No, it's not a trend.
It's in perpetuity.
- [Female] Yeah.
So do you reckon it's a good idea
starting to invest in
like let's say Beyond Meat
or whatever type of company it is?
- Yeah.
The problem is,
there's a lot of people
that think how you think.
So there's yes,
I think they'll be vegan-based companies
that are successful in the next 20 years.
I also think that 98% of them will fail.
But I do like the idea of investing
in places that you know
or are passionate about.
- Okay, awesome, thank you.
- I do like that.
You're welcome.
I do like where you're going with that.
I just want to make sure that you realize
because it's a macro trend,
they'll be a lot of losing.
Not everybody gets to win,
just like a lot of people
have lost in social media
but the macro trend was right.
Got it?
- [Female] Yes, awesome, thank you.
- Okay cool.
Hey.
- [Elizabeth] Hi Gary.
My name's Elizabeth Ann Walker.
Thank you for coming.
- Thank you.
- [Elizabeth] I love your heart.
I love your scarf.
- [Elizabeth] Thank you.
I help people realize
and actualize their dreams.
And in 2008,
I got on social media for the first time
because this weird guy
from New York told me to.
I've built a business,
at that time, it saved my
life, literally, it did.
It was the only way I could
communicate with people
because I'd walked away
from someone who'd hurt me
that should've loved me.
- I understand.
- [Elizabeth] Nine days ago,
you told us, well you
told me, to get on TikTok.
The first video I did is
now up to 63,000 views.
So thank you.
How do I make that happen
for the other videos
because they're sitting
between 200 and 1,000?
So I want to know what's the strategy?
The first video was hey,
is there anyone from Australia on this app
because I can't see any Australians here?
It's gone wild.
What do I need to do
to actualize this platform?
Because I freaking love it.
- I think you just need to keep making.
- [Elizabeth] Great.
- Think about it--
- So just volume?
- It's just volume.
You got to try things.
The biggest struggle
this collective room has
is they don't break out of their box
'cause they're worried about judgment
or they're worried about
short term success.
When you didn't know any better,
you made the best video you've made.
You understand?
- Yep, yep.
My kids were like, no,
you can't be on TikTok.
- Of course.
Every time I do this,
I get a huge influx of kids saying,
you fucker, this was my place.
And I'm like sorry,
marketers ruin everything.
So just keep trying shit.
- [Elizabeth] Awesome, thank you.
- You got it.
- [Elizabeth] Thank you.
- Thanks for the kind words.
Hey.
- [Ben] G'day Jerry, Gary, my name's Ben.
- Hey Ben.
- You guys are putting me off.
My question is
how do you get the most out of your team
from day to day to week to week?
Yeah, how do you put
a fire under their ass
and get the most out of them?
- By realizing that I work for them,
not the other way around.
I think most people suck at being bosses
because they think that their
employees owe them something
for what they pay them for.
And I think of it the other way around
which is I pay them and I owe it to them
to put them in a position to succeed.
So I spend all my time listening
and understanding
whether it's positive word reinforcement,
finances,
work/life balance,
title, or whatever it might be
that actually makes them go.
Most people have a one size fits all.
Most people try to make
their employees act like them
and it's the biggest mistake of all time.
People would be stunned if
they came to VaynerMedia
of how few people are
in the office at six PM
from somebody that hustles.
I don't hold my employees
accountable to my framework.
I'm in the business of listening to them
on an individual basis
to figure out how to get
them motivated and happy.
- [Ben] Yeah, I love that.
Do you mind if I get one more quick one?
If you say do events
or you maybe take on a new client
or whatever it may be,
how do you get them excited
and see the passion and the vision
that you want to instill within this event
or the client or something, a new project?
- At the employee level
or at the client level?
- [Ben] Yeah.
So I take on clients
and I look after different media projects.
If I take on someone
and I see this grand vision
but say it's in flooring products
and generally we work with florists,
how do I really start
installing that vision
and try to portray something long term?
- To the client?
- [Ben] No sorry, I've sold the client.
To my staff, who are managing the account,
who are creating the content,
who are looking at my vision?
- By firing the ones that don't.
- [Ben] Okay.
- Do you understand?
- [Ben] Yeah, elimination.
- 100%.
People are confused,
hiring is guessing,
firing is knowing.
- [Ben] Cheers, thank you.
- Cheers to that shit.
Yo.
- [Male] Yo.
I'm just gonna read this
'cause I'm nervous
and I'll fuck it up otherwise.
- No worries, mate.
Don't worry, go ahead.
- [Male] A few years ago,
I was going through a
really rough time in my life
and I was trying a whole lot of things
and I was getting a whole
lot of shit from friends,
like my closest friends.
- Yes.
- [Male] They're not my friends anymore.
- Good.
- [Male] At that time,
all of that was happening was in 2016,
was at the time when I heart about you
and started learning off your content.
One of the things I decided to try
and am now continuing and pushing hard
is my lifelong passion of music.
And so I wrote a song
called Winning This Game
which actually features a recording
of one of your quotes
and it has you in it
because it's so relevant
and helped me so much.
- Thank you.
- [Male] It sounded a bit like
find new friends,
I'm being dead serious about this,
you are whatever of your
five closest friends,
that shit, put it in a fucking bank.
So the question I have is actually
to ask your permission
to have it featured on my song.
- Done.
- [Male] And if I can give
you this piece of paper
to remind you to listen to it
and as I put my heart and soul into it
and I know you will love it
and thank you so much for
being so inspirational.
- The permission's granted.
Don't give me the paper
'cause I'll lose it.
But if you email me and in the title say,
I'm the dude that came to the mic
and told you about this,
like put it all in the title
and put the link in the body
and I'll listen to it.
- [Male] Okay cool.
- Awesome mate, thank you.
Let me get five more.
You can extend it a little bit.
Hey.
- [Christine] Hey Gary.
Christine from Peanut Butter Bar.
I've been stalking you
for the last two weeks.
- How are you?
- [Christine] How are you?
I hope our video made you smile somehow.
- Yes.
- [Christine] My question to you
is regarding rebranding.
So we are the world's first
peanut butter dessert bar
and two years in we've now realized
we have to change direction
and our brand ID.
My question is regarding
repoire and credibility.
What happens to all our customers
and all the hype that we've created
over the last two years
and how do we kind of continue
with that credibility?
- You make the campaign very predicated
on the name change.
Like you make it a fun positive event
and so what you need to,
when you completely rebrand,
what are you gonna rebrand to?
- [Christine] Well, the
name will stay the same
but the ID will change.
So we're currently very niche
and now we're going into more of a mass
kind of approach.
- [Christine] So when
we're moving from fitness
to sort of peanut butter obsession.
- Help me a little more
'cause I want to give
you the right answer.
You've been doing what?
- [Christine] We've been
focused on the fitness market.
So sort of high protein desserts,
dumb bells and muscles
and now we're sort of dropping that
and going into peanut
butter addict universe.
- And so what are you worried about?
- [Christine] Well,
we're changing the logo,
we're changing the ID,
sort of the communication,
and we're just worried
about the credibility.
So we've taken people on
a journey for two years
and now we're kind of
pivoting to another communication.
- And you'd like to keep
them is what you're saying?
- [Christine] We want to keep
the ones that we've created up until now
and we don't want to sort of lose
the faith and the relationship we've built
with these existing customers.
- But when you change your tone,
that's inevitably gonna happen
with a percentage of them.
- [Christine] So just continue on
and sort of try and create a new universe
around the brand?
- That's the decision you've already made.
- [Christine] Fair enough.
- Do you understand though?
- [Christine] No, I understand.
I'm just worried about credibility--
- But you've made that decision.
- [Christine] Fair enough.
I get it, I get it.
- Good.
Once you've made that decision
and you've done it,
it sounds like, in my opinion,
probably good reasons,
you can't have your cake and eat it too.
You're trying to go to a broader market
and you're gonna lose a percentage
of your niche market
when you make that transition.
- [Christine] We're just
trying to be greedy I guess
sort of--
- Greed fucking sucks.
- Thank you so much.
- What you're being
is ideological and
hopeful, and that's fine.
But if you spent every second
that you just asked me that question
about how to make sure the new audience
grows so fast that you never feel
that you lost any percentage
of your old audience,
you'd be in a much better place.
- [Christine] Fair enough.
- You see where I'm going?
- [Christine] Yeah.
- That's what you have to do.
Once you've made that decision,
you need to put all your
eggs in that basket,
not be hopeful of what will happen.
And that's where a lot
of people get caught.
They can't deal with
the one step backwards
for the two steps forward.
And what I'm trying to do
is get you into a mindset
of being obsessed with
three steps forward,
so you don't even feel
the one step backwards.
- [Christine] Awesome, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
- Yeah, you got it.
Hello.
- [Sean] Hey Gary,
how are you?
I'm Sean.
- Sean, how are you?
- [Sean] Good, thank you.
Just to give you context about me,
I'm a sub teacher.
That's important 'cause
I gave up a day of work
to be here today.
- That's good, good decision.
- [Sean] You inspired me
to make my own podcast
with a friend of mine.
We target 16 to 30 year olds.
We talk conspiracies,
trends, current affairs,
try and add some comedic value to it.
We do my own version of Trash Talk
and show the kids and adults
that we can make extra income
and I update the listeners
on my wins and my losses along the way.
- I like that.
- [Sean] But also I want
to talk sports education
and give advice where I
have qualification to do so.
So my question is
should I put all the topics
under the same umbrella
or should I branch out
and create other channels
and other brands?
- No.
- [Sean] Would it be optimal
to keep everyone under the same umbrella
so they are the same listeners?
- Yes.
- [Sean] Okay cool, thank you very much.
- Good, thank you.
I think in a world that we're in now,
the uniqueness of your hodge podge
and potpourri of subject matters
is your strength, not your weakness
and if you created four
brands, you'd sink.
- [Nick] Hey Gary.
I'm Nick.
So right now I'm 16 and in high school
and I want to be an entrepreneur,
just like yous and all that.
So what advice would you give me?
Do you reckon like
completely disregard school
and focus all on entrepreneurship?
- Yes.
- [Nick] Yep, like personal brand?
I would, if you think
you're an entrepreneur,
you need to find out,
and I don't think 16's
too young to know this,
you need to really ask yourself
if you're trying to force
yourself to be an entrepreneur
'cause it's cool
or if it's who you actually are.
Wanting to be one,
I want to be a fucking
quarterback of the New York Jets.
Wanting something versus
being capable of it
are two very different things.
If you truly are an entrepreneur,
yes, I think you can punt school.
If you're doing it 'cause
it's the thing now,
then you're gonna be vulnerable.
- [Nick] Yeah, I'm just doing it
to like get ahead,
get out of the rat race.
- That's an ideology.
Rat race of what?
- [Nick] Life.
- Like bullshit school
that makes you do nothing.
That's not a rat race,
that's a fucking vacation, bro.
- [Nick] Yeah, get out
as early as possible
before going to uni and all that.
- But I just want to make sure
that you're not being
ideological about it.
And it's like,
I just want to make sure,
lot of kids are like,
yo, I'm gonna do this.
I'm like, cool, are you
good at selling stuff?
Do you have a good idea?
Are you willing to put in the work ethic?
A lot of kids that suck at school
look at entrepreneurship as the vacation.
Entrepreneurship is way
fucking harder than school.
- [Nick] Yeah.
- Are you good at selling shit?
Right now, I have like Instagram account.
I have like 80,000 followers.
I upload like music--
- Do you make money, bro?
- [Nick] Yeah.
- How much?
- [Nick] So I was earning about 4,000
the past three months
just from like shout-outs--
- That's a good start.
Yeah, quit school.
- [Nick] Thanks.
- You got it.
- [Male] G'day.
- G'day.
- [Male] My question is
in a world where business is about giving,
what is the right motivation
for attempting to make profit
as opposed to just being a charity?
- Because you want to.
There's nothing wrong with making profit.
In the same way that there's nothing wrong
with being fully in a charity mindset.
The motivation is you chose to
for whatever reason.
You know what I mean?
- [Male] Yeah.
- I think this is something
that some people struggle with.
It's funny,
when I wrote Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook,
I thought I was writing it
for people that were just always spamming
and I needed to show
them how to bring value
so that they could close their sale.
What I realized after writing it
was it was really written for people
that always give value
and it gave them permission
to ask for a sale.
There's nothing wrong
with generating profit
because at the end of the day,
if you choose that that's
what you want to do,
then that's more than okay.
I think doing good
is a competitive advantage for businesses.
- [Male] Okay.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
We're gonna do a couple more.
I'm sorry.
I've been over time for awhile now.
Go ahead.
- [Argen] Hey Gary.
My name's Argen from Investicate,
a buyer's agency for residential
and commercial investors.
I just wanted to say a
massive, massive thank you
because you have enabled me
to just focus so hard
on reinvesting in myself
and in business.
I haven't taken a dollar for myself
for like the last year.
And it's just been phenomenal.
But where the business is now
is I really want to scale out
with different solutions of
technology and education.
But at the same time,
I have my core business of buyer's agency.
A part of me goes
do you put them under different brands
and try and connect them
but then a part of me goes,
no, you're building this community
and you can help them in so many ways.
How do you sort of make
these types of decisions
so you don't feel
like you're cramming
your audience too much
when at the same time
you could separate it?
- You pick a decision,
'cause both could work,
and you live with it.
- [Argen] Cool.
- I think so.
- [Argen] Do you feel that sometimes
you can create a brand disconnect
from putting too many things
or in your experience of scaling
and adding services and products--
- Not if you're able to execute.
When Apple decided to make a phone
and not just an iPod, that worked,
because it was good.
- [Argen] Yeah, no, fair call.
- The whole game for everybody,
for all of us, is execution.
You can do anything if you do it well.
- [Argen] Thank you so much man.
- Everybody told me to
stay in the wine business
and I would never be
successful in advertising.
That seemed like far
fetched and disconnected.
I just thought I could do it well.
And so the answer is
yes if you can execute.
Last one.
- [Male] Cool.
Hey Gary, I teach people how to sing
and I absolutely love it.
And I'm gradually growing it
but I'm not making enough
to take care of my mom
who's got a disability.
So my question is from your experience
is this just a game of patience?
- Maybe.
And what I mean by that is
what I would really audit
is every other minute
besides you teaching people to sing
and you having to do
another job in addition
to help a mother who's disabled.
You know what I mean?
- [Male] Yeah.
- Maybe you'll click
and get the right client
who gets you another 30 clients
and all of a sudden,
you're right there.
The other option you have
is to audit every other hour that you have
that isn't in the full time job
and the side hustle of singing
that may allow you to do
more of the singing stuff.
Do you see what I mean?
- [Male] Yeah.
- Usually, the thing,
when people have to do two things
that they have to focus on
is auditing their leisure
so that they can pour more time
into their side hustle
so that the side hustle can actually grow
while they're keeping something
that makes the practicality
of their short term needs viable.
- [Male] Cool, thank you so much.
- In the way that those questions went,
I think half the time it's affirmation.
I think the other half to the time is
my lack of education and my lack
of paying attention to other voices
has created an extremely simple framework
where the answer's simple
and they weren't looking for affirmation,
they just had so many
contradictory thoughts
that getting the simplicity of the answer
just created clarity.
I think the far majority
of people overthink shit.
And so it's either affirmation
or it's simplicity.
- [Male] Excellent.
I set you up tonight
as if you were gonna be a,
like a bat out of hell.
- I heard.
- [Male] How often are you in this
really connected peaceful power?
- Like one in every like 20
to 30 talks this comes out
and I'm always interested in it.
It's not predicated on being tired.
I always think when I
do this, do they think,
it's predicated on I'm in mid thought.
A lot of times when it happens,
I can feel myself in a zone
where I'm just so quiet and it doesn't,
I also am very thoughtful.
What I mean by that is
this is now the third time I'm at Sydney
in less than two and a half years.
And so I'm always thoughtful of
most of this room,
whether they've seen it
physically here or online,
have gotten the energy thing.
I thought tonight,
I think of myself as
somebody who's trying to find
different angles to connect
and I think this tone with
this information tonight
for a lot of people might
be, not disappointing,
but sometimes when you go
see your favorite band,
you want to hear the hits.
And other times, you want
to hear something else.
And for me, I'm desperate
to get people to win.
And if I can throw this off
speed pitch or curve ball
and because I did,
this was the time something
penetrated their mind
because the beat of the
cadence of what I normally do
has become mundane and they're used to it,
I'm always trying to do things
that bring value
and intuitively tonight here,
I felt this was the right tone and tenor
and that's what I went with.
(audience cheering)
Sydney, thank you so much.
I love you guys.
- [Male] Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience applause)